- 6 o'clock or so,
Monday morning.
Los Angeles,
ready to rock 'n roll.
Was away for the week,
family time
and feel super recharged
and ready to go.
Super excited about this week.
Great day in L.A.
today, action-packed.
Couple days in New York, got a
quick trip to Dallas and back.
Same day on Thursday and
on Friday some early morning
important meetings
and then heading out
for fantasy
baseball draft weekend.
One of my favorite
weekends of the year.
So it's gonna be a
great, great, great, great week.
Hotel new what my
second favorite number is.
By the way, that's
my favorite number.
But that's how many
days I like to go hard.
Mentally, at least.
("Monday To Monday" by Saba)
Saba, I've been telling you.
("Interlude Type Beat"
by LifeThroughPablo)
Thank you so much.
- [Man] You're welcome.
- [Gary] Rolling in L.A.,
going to another meeting.
Just spent two
hours at CAA four,
five different meetings.
Ran into Grant Kessman,
Michael Kives one of the old
homies I signed
with back in 2007.
Got to see a preview
of Planet of the Apps
which was incredible.
It's gonna be good.
Spoke to Peter Jacobson,
my speaking world.
Met some new characters around
voiceovers and podcasts and
stuff of that nature.
Feeling pretty good
and really excited
and so having a very
productive day so far in L.A.
Did a VaynerSports
meeting earlier today.
Met with the head of our
creative team
here in L.A., Juliette.
Fun to see her.
Had a lovely meeting
with a former employee.
Strategizing long-term
and just an awfully productive
three or four hours,
mainly off the record.
Sorry DRock.
- [DRock] It's alright.
- Can we have a sad DRock face?
Actually I'm gonna do this.
DRock, it's been very off the
record so far today in L.A.
Make the sad
DRock face. (laughs)
That was good.
Too bad you won't be
able to use any of it.
- [DRock] I can.
- Oh, you'll put music over it
You know how to edit.
("Can You Swim" by
Lilo Key ft. Renz Young)
That's what's
good about me, right?
When I don't know, I
say that I don't know.
When I know I
fucking tell you I know.
I'm always adjusting, right?
I mean trading those
second round picks is
gonna change everything.
It's a monster, monster change.
There's one player
that I'm willing to
spend all my money on.
I don't know, man,
it's really good.
I'm really enjoying how
it's evolving, you know?
(laughs)
I can't even imagine
that first four seconds of your
brain when you...
(inaudible) was really good.
That was so funny last year.
I'm so pumped, Brand.
Brand, we have not
hung out a Friday afternoon
to Sunday night in 100 years.
("Can You Swim" by
Lilo Key ft. Renz Young)
(laughs)
Nate, are you
coming to the draft?
Yeah. You're the
core of the team, right?
- [Man] Nobody can never not
know who you are because
of your voice. So I'm
sitting there and I'm thinking.
I'm like I know this
damn voice. (Gary laughs)
I know the voice,
I know the voice.
No, real talk,
I'm sitting there.
I'm like damn.
- [Gary] It's
so familiar, right?
- I know that damn voice.
Gary, just don't stop talking.
(Gary and DRock laugh)
- One more, one more,
one more.
- One more?
- Yeah.
- My man.
- Thank you, brother.
Have a good meeting.
- Keep grinding.
Thank you.
Appreciate it, my man.
Stay well.
What up?
- [Harrison] What's up, my man?
- Life is good.
- [Harrison] 'Sup, man?
I'm Harrison.
- [DRock] DRock.
- [Logic] How you doing?
- [Gary] Hey man. Real pleasure.
- Nice to meet you.
- [Gary] How are you?
- Dude, I'm good.
Thanks for coming.
- [Gary] Yeah, real pleasure.
- [Logic] Nice to meet you.
That kind of Rick and Morty one
and the space ship over there.
- [Gary] Yep.
- [Logic] And so,
I was like wow,
this is really amazing.
And I said how much would it
cost in supplies for you to
paint 20 of them for me?
And he said $300.
So I gave him a grand, and said
go to town and I said once you
get it back to me, I'll do a
vlog and I'm creeping up on a
million subscribers on my
YouTube so I was like I'll do a
vlog and I'll tweet it and I'll
Instagram it and he really did
it and he sent them all to me.
- [Boyd] Leverage!
- [Gary] That's fucking awesome.
- [Logic] Do you
ever shoot pool?
- [Gary] I used
to back in the day.
- [Logic] Do you want to play?
- Why? Are you really good?
- No, I'm okay.
- [Gary] He's really good.
(group laughter)
I'll play. I'm crafty.
When he was finally
starting to make it in America.
Stupid, AKA the
greatest moments of our lives.
- [Logic] Yeah,
it was pretty crazy.
- [Gary] I thought you told me
you took the music deal for the
tour not for stupid shit.
I'm just kidding.
I'm kidding.
- [Logic] I just signed to Def
Jam for the (inaudible) tour.
- [Gary] Oh! Get in there.
Oh.
I think everybody
actually does have...
("I Just Know" by Bugus)
Ah, that's busted.
I know you did DRock,
I saw you set up perfectly.
We'll be editing that part out.
(group laughter)
- [Logic] I'll take hours
randomly to just talk to
different fans on Twitter or
hold contests and all different
kinds of things.
You know?
Just like really fun
shit to interact with fans.
Where most people they'd get to
a level where they start with
the fans and then they
won't really like--
- Fuck with them, yeah.
- [Logic] Yeah.
So it's just kind of stupid.
But I feel like
interaction is everything.
- That didn't count.
- [Logic] (inaudible) is the
foundation of your career.
- [Gary] Like it doesn't matter
how much Michael Jackson wanted,
if you wanted it too,
you just couldn't.
- [Logic] And it's cool,
it's always...
I don't know I guess...
Play them the album.
- That's the best.
- [Man 2] We could,
if legally, you have to
jump through those...
- [Gary] Logic, at
this point where you at with
going out in public.
Tough, right?
- Yeah, it's crazy everywhere
I go I get recognized but
I don't give a fuck.
It's like I chose this life
so if somebody comes up--
- I totally--
- it's all about respect.
("I Just Know" by Bugus)
- And it's interesting, you got
to pick and choose your battles,
right?
- Yeah.
- [Gary] But I'm like, I think
Logic is exactly right.
I'm always going to
sleep in the bed that I make.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Back to
what he just said.
That's exactly right.
You can't be like trying to
build brand and make stuff
happen and have all the good
stuff that comes along with it
and then cry if
somebody bothers you when
you're eating spaghetti.
- [Logic] Yeah. Yeah.
- I mean you can
do whatever you want.
- [Logics] That's
your perspective, yeah.
- But that's just, I'm
in full agreement with that.
You know?
("I Just Know" by Bugus)
(Gary groans)
(DRock laughs)
(group laughter)
Oh, that hurt.
- Oh shit.
- You love Rubik's Cube?
- Yeah, Rubik's Cube's dope.
- You were super hardcore on it?
- Yeah.
- Like as a kid you
got real good at it?
- Nah, I only learned this
like a year and a half ago.
- And what, you're good now?
- I'm okay. Yeah, I like it.
(Gary laughs)
- You've gotten really good.
- I've gotten okay.
There's people that are so--
- So what?
You watch YouTube
videos to figure it out?
- Yeah.
- It's unbelievable how
that's the answer to every,
that's it. Like how to...
Going live five
minutes for the (inaudible).
Do you ever just go, have you
ever just done a song from top
of the head or do you write?
- I write everything.
Yeah, I believe that,
I mean don't get me wrong,
I've gone in and sure there's
certain songs where I just go in
and there's a vibe or something
but for the most part I really
like to take my time
because I want to be revered
as one of the greatest. So--
- [Gary] That's your process.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] People need
to know their process.
For me, when I speak,
I only can do improv.
- [Logic] Yeah, word.
- I can't write.
- [Logic] I mean
that makes sense,
speaking is like, for
example, when I'm live,
speaking in front of, you know--
- [Gary] Mhmmm.
- 50,000 people it's like yeah,
I'm not just gonna be like ah,
what was I gonna say?
It's moments and there's shit.
There's super fun
things you can do to just--
- [Gary] React
to what's going on?
- Yeah, exactly.
- [Gary] Yeah, yeah.
- What's going on or
whatever the case may be.
- [Gary] It makes sense though
when you think about the right,
like the songs, right.
I mean, I don't know.
Please God be 500
but it's not unlimited.
- [Logic] Yeah.
- Like you're
gonna have your songs.
- [Logic] Yeah.
- That's gonna be your life.
- That's kind of cool.
I'm here with an unbelievable
talent and a better dude.
We're about to
do an #AskGaryVee.
For the four of you that
don't know this is Logic.
Logic, say what's up.
- What's up people?
How's it going?
I'm awkwardly
waving to the camera.
- [Gary] That's good.
That was a good awkward wave.
- Yeah, this is tight.
So Logic is an incredible artist
for the few that don't know.
We're about to go
into an #AskGaryVee.
You'll see in a minute.
- Are we allowed to
curse? Can we curse?
- Dude, the amount of
cursing--
- Pussy hoe!
No, I'm just kidding.
- The amount of
cursing I do is phenomenal.
You'll be super,
super comfortable.
- Okay.
- If you want to curse.
- Cool.
- So we're about to do this.
Hope everybody's super well.
Great to see you.
DRock is here.
DRock.
- [DRock] Hey.
- Glad to be back on the grind?
- [DRock] Yeah, and
now I'm not sad any more.
- [Gary] I know, you got
some good color by the way.
- [DRock] I know I did.
- [Gary] Boyd? You ready?
- [Boyd] Hey.
- Hey.
Alright.
(DRock laughs)
Alright, let's do this.
Alright, got that.
My man, take care of yourself.
- Best of luck.
- [Ryan] Thank you, Gary.
- That's some gangster ass
advice you just gave that dude.
That's so gangster.
- Logic, what about you
as an entrepreneur as a kid?
So you were very artistic.
You were clearly
artistic and thoughtful.
Did you have a selling DNA, were
you like going buying Blow-Pops
and trying to sell 'em?
Did you have that part?
- I'm very ashamed to tell you
a story that I've never told
anyone in my life.
- Here we go.
- So where I come from--
- Let me get coze.
- Yeah, so like when I grew up,
you know what I'm saying,
I was like hella poor.
I didn't have shit.
- Right. You stole
and sold shit?
- No.
- Damn.
- Because I think that's okay.
- No. I went a step further.
- Logic.
- Yes?
- You're a good dude.
- I love you.
- We're good dudes.
- Now, question of the day.
You get to ask everybody
the question of the day.
There'll be thousands of
comments in Facebook and
YouTube to this question.
What's the question you
want to put out to the
13, 14, 15-year-olds and
everybody else in the world?
What would you
like to see them answer?
Might be a good
opportunity for you to get a
little
bit of a feedback loop.
- Yeah.
- You might be able
to get some insight on
something from the masses.
- Man, I didn't know that's
what you were gonna ask me?
- I know.
And notice how I didn't give
you that head's up beforehand.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause this awkward pause
right now is everything to me.
I'm gonna rewind
and watch this part.
Shhh.
This is gonna be
an amazing question.
I'm predicting the greatest
question asked by a guest in the
history of The #AskGaryVee Show.
- Why do you think--
- Oh, this will
be good actually.
Yo, yo! Hope
you guys liked that.
Hope you had fun.
Logic, last parting gifts.
- Thanks for being cool.
- [Gary] That's awesome.
- Go follow me Logic301.
- Love you guys,
talk to you soon.
- [DRock] I think that
was the best all-time.
(group crosstalk)
All-time, all-time great.
- [Logic] That was?
- [DRock] All-time great.
- Logic's a good kid, man.
Real good kid.
Look at this diesel dude.
He's a monster.
Respect the process is so real.
- I follow you, man.
I respect your brand.
- Thank you, my man.
- Yeah, definitely.
- 'Cause of this. This.
The process is the only,
this guy is fucking a monster.
- Oh, Jordan.
- Yeah, look at him. Looks good.
Jordan will destroy
your soul with a look.
What are we doing?
- Yeah, let's do a photo.
- Do it for the 'Gram?
- [Gary] Do it for the 'Gram.
- [DRock] Good
meeting you. Thank you.
- [Logic] A pleasure, of course.
- [Harrison] Good stuff,
Gary. Thanks for everything.
- My pleasure, my man.
You guys ever
throw shit at this tower?
- [Logic] We
shoot a BB gun at it.
(group laughter)
- [Harrison] That's your answer.
- [Gary] It was
just too obvious.
You have to do
something with it.
Okay, alright guys.
- [DRock] Later guys.
- [Gary] Stay well.
Yeah, early transformation.
Airport Gary. Hustle.
("Interlude Type Beat"
by LifeThroughPablo)
L.A. good trip.
Logic, you're a legend.
Got some work done.
These guys are hustling too.
That's it.
Red eye. NYC. Cool.
("Interlude Type Beat"
by LifeThroughPablo)